by the way he was on rogan did you guys
see tim dillon and was it tim i didn't
see i saw that he did it
and and the left is going after him like
hard oh i haven't seen i only watched a
few
these people don't know why they're mad
at alex jones they really have no idea
he's funny he's a community sandy hook
check this out though i i thought of
something i was thinking of something
really checking i did a segment on this
there was a recently jacobin magazine
which i'm sure you guys found it's the
social socialist magazine
first i want to say my respects to
jacobin they've done repeated articles
defending free speech
arguing that if they give in to
restrictions on fascist speech
the government will go after them next
and i'm like yes yes exactly
and so they said like they called it
like the anti-fascist hate speech
boomerang was an article they wrote
where they basically said we cannot give
in to these demands to censor speech
because they're going to come for us so
i respect that they did a show
it got censored on facebook and one of
the hosts of that show was was on the
young turks
so while i'll give my respects to
jacobin for defending free speech
because they understand how important it
is for us for a movement like theirs
especially
the host they had from the young turks
was in favor of censoring alex jones
and so i thought about something i was
like how many how many decades of
content does alex jones have
right like three three decades and that
means he's probably got
out of those decades of work he's done
how much how many
hours of content sixty thousand well i
mean he didn't
work literally was my first it's
probably a really ridiculously
huge number right how many videos did he
have on youtube honey subscribers
because he said one thing
he's gone forever and every bit of
speech he ever said think about how
insane that is
that you could you could you could talk
for 30 years
and then say and also this oh there it
is get them
and they they delete literally
everything you've ever said
not just the things you're saying now
everything you've ever
said that's crazy and here's what's
really crazy about it
the stuff that jones was saying as
reprehensible as it was for sure
was like what seven years before they
went after him it was from a long time
ago
yeah it was from a long time you
remember the incident involved
oliver darcy yeah of course yeah right
it was about
uh alex jones confronting him in the
halls of the capitol building
and basically being a [ __ ] and and
like cornering him and intimidating him
and believe me oliver darcy if you're
watching
there's no love lost here right i met
oliver years ago back at business
insider when he was there and
he was trying and he was writing
favorable articles he was trying to be
all chummy with us maga crew in dc
and showing up at all the events him and
rosie gray and andrew marantz and they
all just
turned you know that uh oliver darcy
interviewed me when the alt-right got
banned and i said
slippery slope we can't just ban people
for bad opinions and he wrote an article
about it
news like you know renowned journalists
or whatever warns of the coming
censorship
business insider then he got hired by
cnn
and you know rosie cheeked oliver darcy
walked in with a smile on his face like
looking up at the big building and all
the floors and he was like i finally
made it
and that's when jeff sucker jumped out
of the shadows and latched onto his back
and sunk his teeth into his neck and
olive oil
and then turn into a fake new zombie
that's exactly right they turned out i
mean they turned him into the schoolyard
snitch
yeah like he's got to be like the most
the most hated of all of those people
from that time
and he's really sort of sold himself on
that but anyway
that was for alex jones he got banned
off of twitter for what he did outside
of twitter
that's so crazy but it was years before
and it's like
what if the main issue i see is if you
say
one wrong thing years ago and we decide
now that was wrong we eliminate
everything you've ever said from the
record now i i'm working with mines
and and banning accounts and being in
charge of that kind of thing i was of
the ilk that if
so if an account violated the terms i
don't care who the human is
using that account that count is nuked
i'm not going after the person if the
person makes a new account it's fine
it does they violated terms with that
account that account is gone it's not
the person
and that's where cancel culture comes
from the pro
the problem i'm seeing you know as i
think about what happened with alex
jones and so so anyway the gist of it
was that you know one of the young turks
people on the show was like i'm glad
alex jones can't harass people
and i'm like so you're okay with him
having literally every bit of his work
removed and annihilated because
he did this one wrong thing and i guess
he did a couple times i'm not you know i
think what he did was wrong for sure
reprehensible and you tell him hey that
thing you did don't do it again
okay okay no they didn't i think he
remained on facebook for a while and
they were just waiting to press the nuke
button give them an excuse and then they
went for it
so it really was not about just that one
thing you said it was a political move
they didn't like this guy he had too
much influence and he says crazy stuff
so they were like he's a problem to get
rid of him and find any excuse to do it
the funny thing about i watched like
maybe the first half hour the joe rogan
show with him and uh alex starts to say
something that seemed all crazy and
joe's like no no no no hold on what you
need is a fact checker
let's fact check this one come on we're
gonna factor it to lydia jamie jimmy
bring it up bring it up
bring it up and jones was right they
brought it up and he's reading and he's
like
oh holy crap right yeah do you know what
he was saying yeah he said that uh
corporations were making payments to sub
level lower level staff members in the
trump organization because trump is
uncorruptable he's not beholden to
lobbyists he's not beholden to
corporations
and so that he's saying that
corporations were going towards people
in his orbit and below him in order to
get influence
and the example he's like he's like yeah
att paid people you know
millions of dollars just to get access
and they're like whoa hold on a second
and then they checked in and they pull
it up usa today i think is what it was
this is snap this is this is the thing
it's low information individuals with
power
who don't know what they're talking
about and getting mad about it the other
day when we had vashon
he mentioned that i got into like
conspiracy realm stuff
and he mentioned you said if joe biden
gets elected they're gonna come to your
house they're gonna change definitions
and i was like they've done both of
those things already
like i i wasn't i didn't say here's my
prediction of the future
i said here's what they've already done
if joe biden gets elected
it like locks that in it it exacerbates
well that's his argument was
because it happened doesn't mean that
something's going to trigger to happen
again you didn't say that
yeah that's what he's saying if a toilet
exploded in someone's house and you say
hey if that guy gets elected there's
going to be exploding toilets
he said that after i said those things
already happened and then he went oh
well just because
his initial argument was he didn't know
people have already gone to several
houses peop and then he was like which
people and i was like the mccloskeys for
one he's like oh okay
so clearly i want to go more into that
too there are many more people
i really do think one of the biggest
issues between left and right is the
sources we consume
but it is a fact that the right knows
the left is thinking the left does not
know what the right is thinking
the best example of this is when the
hashtag proud boys went viral
and it was a bunch of like gay men
kissing and they were like take that
proud boys
and then enrique like uh posted milo and
gavin making out like
what are you talking about like yeah so
what do you think this is somebody once
took the graphics for a liminal order
and they like put made it in rainbow
flag and they were and they tried
to make it out like this was like being
being mean to me
like oh they made it look like it was
the gay flag like they don't know who
you are
like you've repeatedly said that uh uh
the republican party accepting gay
marriage was was what allowed you to be
like okay i can go in this direction
yeah
i'm socially accepting absolutely and
just piggybacking off your your
uh idea there that the left does not
know what the bright is thinking but the
right does know what the left is
thinking
i have made a terrible mistake i have
re-engaged with my old friends
on facebook in this election season and
it was a big mistake it's a big mistake
there's no question
and and i was i would just had it
totally reconfirmed to me
when i'm trying to explain to them sort
of their thought process
because i know it like i've studied
critical race there i've studied radical
feminism i've studied intersectionality
i know how it works
i know there are sort of kafka traps i
know their intellectual you know
framework if you can call it that
and i'm explaining it to them and they
don't even know they're just all foot
soldiers that have been
sort of co-opted by black lives matter
antifa cetera
and they think they're doing a good
thing they're like yeah black lives
matter of course black lives matter
class of course
but they don't understand what the
system is that they're in
and it's just i try to engage with them
it's just it's not possible
and uh i i just i have this hope i had
this naive notion
that in like five years when maybe
everything just completely falls apart
and everybody suffers a traumatic
experience they need
in order to rethink their worldview that
one of them at least is just gonna be
like
oh you know that jack he was right yeah
they will no i don't know about that
they come out they're never gonna do it
never never the interesting thing we
were talking about earlier when you
mentioned
rewiring in your brain yeah is that they
people do trainings where they tell you
to tell yourself things to do that
yeah and so you think about these people
who are watching tv and say black lives
matter everywhere
it becomes they have no idea what it is
but they just adhere to it and when you
challenge it you threaten their world
view yeah
so i think a lot of the reason we see
like anti-fog getting crazy and foaming
at the mouth i'm like wow
black lives matter because they are
righteous and just
they don't know why but they've said it
over and over and over again and it's in
their being and so when you
are opposition when you are the other
you are the evil villain destroying the
world and they have no idea why
you you ask them they couldn't tell you
i've tried
when it comes to black lives matter yeah
i know me i feel like there's three
strata of the way that people interact
or interface with that movement one is
like the
ideological one where it's like why is
black lives matter why does it exist and
this is kind of what bosh was kind of
hinting at that last night
um you know it's a it's a class issue
thing that's caused this thing to erupt
then there's the people that are like
in it and using it as a business and
profiting from it in a lot of ways
and then and then there's like the foot
soldiers who are like yeah black lives
are great
so i follow it they don't know anything
about it right but
that's and that's most people like i i
have friends and family that are posting
things like
it is not enough to be not racist you
must be actively anti-racist and i was
like
what does that mean and they can't give
me an answer i once did this really
thoughtful post about the problems of
leftist identitarianism and critical
race theory
and tried explaining to them using their
own words and language
and they just said you know f off
basically yeah like i'm sorry we're in
the tribe
the tribe is good you say bad you bad
i have pity i have pity for them because
they do believe that they're possessed
in like a spiritual demon way maybe but
they're possessed by
an idea uh i think it was jordan
peterson that said that people don't
have ideas ideas have people yes
and these people these ideas got these
people right and
and it's really it just it makes me sad
when i can see people that i
i know are otherwise decent good humans
that that are just acting in a way that
i know if they really understood
that they would change their mind
because they are good decent people
and this is sort of the mission and
there's there i see a path to redemption
for them
but they don't see a path to redemption
for me
and and just to finish up on this the
suffrage the suffering sessions or
struggle struggle sessions copter
chapters um
you know think about it in reverse
you visualize success you tell yourself
success you say it over and over again
i'm going to do this i'm going to be
great at that i am this i am this thing
i want to become
because you can rewire your brain using
your self-talk and the things you say so
you can do it in the other direction
they said raise the fist
that's the thing that stood out to me is
the guy the intensity
nosed up in here coughing their corona
all over me
whose side are you on [ __ ]
and when i wouldn't it's just like oh
these just they just explode inside
their heads it's all it's
not awful for them think about this you
got you got a nice beanie there good sir
there's a symbol on that beanie what is
that symbol that symbol is the logo for
the liminal order my all men's
organization national 300 members you've
got a national organization
and i i take a lot of people often want
to join and you get like you know you
put the word out and then people hit you
up 3 000 people on the waiting list
imagine if you had mainstream dominant
culture
promoting the ideology for you and you
needed only walk up and say
you think black lives matter right okay
well join my organization
slick yeah so imagine
you all of us as critical thinkers and
the people watching
who would challenge what we're told and
be like let me check on that first
and that's a big thing about the
internet is a lot of people who consume
news are actively looking for it
as opposed to mainstream media which is
they're sitting there absorbing it
so you're more likely to find people who
know more about specific things they're
seeking it out
now imagine you've got half the people
who are just absorbing information have
no idea
never challenged it's true it was on the
tv if you
want to use them for your advantage in
your power
well if you go up to them and say black
lives matter is
you know out of control identitarianism
and while i i can understand the
the core complaints and i can agree
please brutality is bad we respect his
lives the movement
has its problems now join me they're
going to be like screw you
what are you racist if you go up to them
and say
you want to join a black lives matter
group right you're not racist are you
then yeah you're right you're right yes
because dominant culture told them too
are you yep you're not racist it's it's
the issue is you've got this person
right and they see you walk up to them
and you say
give me your money and your time and
your energy and they say
why should i do that and they say look
around you you're not a racist are you
and they see signs everywhere black
lives matter black lives matter
and they're like i don't want to be
another i don't want to be another here
whatever you want from me please just
don't ostracize me
so i think a big component of a lot of
whatever like this moderate space
intellectual space whatever you want to
call it
or a bunch of just i don't know
rebellious morons if that's
apt i think it's it's just an issue of
people who are self-sufficient to a
certain degree not too concerned about
being ostracized
i would rather live on my feet than die
on my knees
versus people who would let rather live
on their knees than die yeah
i'm comfortable being the other that's
how it's always been my life i've always
been contrarian counter culture that's
just where i feel more comfortable
but on this issue of passive versus
intentional learning or understanding we
in a little order have come up with a
name we didn't determine this name but
we've determined that it's an essential
tool in this world it's called sense
making and sense making is
intentional understanding and part of
intentional understanding
is a a desire to want to actually make
sense of the world
and b it's also an internal process
where you have to
understand your emotional triggers
understand what states you are in
uh that lead to emotional triggers and
irrational behavior
and it's a process by which you learn
how to control your emotions your
emotional
uh triggers your your physical integrity
in order
to increase your ability to discern
between right and wrong good and bad
so that you can be an intentional
understander
and and do this art of sense-making so
if you want to be
an independent sovereign person in an
information
war space which is where we are and the
information battlefield is deliberately
polluted at all times
if you want to maintain your sense of
personal sovereignty you have to develop
this
skill of sense-making and that's one of
the things we do in the liminal order
because we think it's vital it's like a
life skill at this point well we get on
the other side
willful ignorance yeah which is kind of
like the other end of the spectrum of
that
people who just choose to be swimming in
bliss
yeah ignorance is bliss man i mean there
is some truth to that thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you